welcome back to Yale and
mission what we're going to do is just
lead a conversation about the Affordable
Care Act and where we go from here we'll
start out chatting but we also want to
hear from you we want this to be as
interactive as we can my name is Zack
Cooper I'm a faculty member here in the
Department of Health Policy and
management and then in our department of
economics I also run the Center for
healthcare policy at Yale and yeah I'd
say it's not an exaggeration to say that
health care's is probably the most
important issue right now in the US
domestic agenda so health care is 17.6
percent of u.s. gdp it's a shocking
number one in every six dollars the u.s.
spends goes to health care and if we
think about growth the the growth and
health care spending that's where the
real issues are so we see median
household incomes that haven't increased
in the US in 15 years and the real
reason that hasn't happened is because
of rising health care costs and the rub
is well we spend more than any other
country on health care it's not clear
that we get more so we've got life
expectancy that lags behind Greece
infant mortality that's way too high
there's a lot of good in the US health
care system the amazing organizations
and we'll talk about our amazing
organization here but where do we go and
sort of queue up the the Affordable Care
Act the most dramatic piece of social
policy legislation and in you know I
think the last 50 years certainly the
biggest health care reform since the
introduction of Medicare in 1965 it's a
reform that changed the way Medicare
pays for healthcare that introduces some
pretty wide-ranging changes to our
insurance markets that we'll talk about
it hasn't been at all controversial it's
it's nothing not too big a deal the
latest gallup polling out two weeks ago
so forty-eight percent of americans
still don't approve of the law
forty-seven percent do there have also
been 462 attempts by Congress in the
Senate to repeal the law so I couldn't
think of two better people to better
Yale alumni I'm not a yellow um now I'm
just I'm here for moral support but two
remarkable
I'm not here to to share the
conversation with me marna borgstrom is
needs no introduction she's a graduate
of our school of public health right now
she's the president and CEO of Yale New
Haven Hospital and the Yale New Haven
health system she joined it I think
straight after your mph as a management
fellow took over the helm of the
organization 2005 it's a health system
that's got two billion dollars in
revenue annually 3.6 like I said 3.6 3.6
a billion here a billion there
eventually well yale-new Haven Hospital
is to billions okay okay got that part
13 I have 13,000 people employed in
Connecticut is up 21 21,000 people
employed in Connecticut should I should
let you introduce yourself right it's
growing ready righties actually it added
a couple thousand last week and and then
Harlan krumholz who also needs no
introduction who's the Hal Heinz
professor of medicine here at Yale and
it really one of the leading
cardiologists in the nation if not the
world but also when leading health
services researchers what blew me away
is he's written 800 peer review articles
where do you find the time man and then
trying to not make me feel as bad about
myself is you do so let's let's just
start but I think Marta hat how's the
ACA affected Yale New Haven house it
how's it affected you have you have you
noticed it well we we've noticed it and
actually will probably take you off if
there's a script because you know we can
talk about the ACA but you said
something in your introduction that will
bring me back to channeling my friend
Betsy Bradley about you know what we
spend money on and what we get for it
but you know I think in a nutshell you
know when the ACA was being developed we
very early on jumped on board and said
this is an imperfect idea in perfect
peace of policy but you know we need to
move forward and we've got to start
somewhere and
you know and so we have always been a
supporter of the concepts behind the
Affordable Care Act because I think that
you know for most of us who have been in
some aspect of healthcare delivery the
thought of people not having coverage
and therefore not feeling that they had
access to care is a very troublesome
concept and i think that the Affordable
Care Act has helped I in certain ways to
get some people access to insurance but
I would say that it's you know we still
have a long way to go because it's
largely been insurance legislation
rather than healthcare delivery I don't
think that it has been able to help
deliver on the promise of enhancing
access for a whole lot of reasons but
you know I think that it was the right
place to go at the right time hmm what
do you think the ACA were but a year on
from the full implementation we we the
better for it well I am pleased first I
just want to save Martin is an
extraordinary leader and you know that
response of saying you know we're behind
it and we're going to figure out how to
make it work is is a is one of
leadership of saying you know how are we
going to make things better and how
we're going to deal with what the
situation we have I don't think think
question that we're better off now than
we were before I always find it
perplexing that the polls would say that
half the people aren't for it i think i
think the ask them what they're not for
they have trouble saying what they're
not for it has to do with the polarized
political nature of our society and the
idea of what obamacare represents not
actually what the content of it but what
it represents in the political sphere in
and by being for Obamacare you're here
for a party or for president your for
certain other policies but you can't
really understand exactly what it is
that the legislation itself you know to
say it's incomplete I mean I think it's
good for everyone to have a really good
sense of this it's not just saying that
the legislation was unsuccessful in
achieving a sort of amateur vision of
where the next part of healthcare should
go but it truly is incomplete it wasn't
done
I mean the senate-passed Obama made a
decision that he couldn't bring the
Republicans on and so he goes to bacchus
and says we're going to go it alone
we're going to go it alone because
otherwise we're going to get stuff the
Republicans are just not not
participating with us in a way that's
going to help us create this legislation
they go energy first and then health is
going to go next and so they make the
this fateful decision that they're going
to go with no Republican votes and make
this thing work you can argue about
whether that was wise weather was going
to come back to bite them it certainly
wasn't going to help the country come
together but it wasn't clear that if he
went the other way you were ever going
to get any health legislation so the
commitment was to say we've got needs in
this country that supersede the need for
us to worry about partisan politics and
if they're not going to work with us we
need to make it happen but then what
happens is finally a lot of fighting the
house has got their ideas of what this
bill should look like Senate's got their
idea of what the bill should look like
the end of the day finally after a lot
of wrangling and some special deals that
were cut surprised Senate passes and the
house is working on it and this is the
reason they got the Senate to pass it by
the way was because when Kennedy dies it
becomes a rallying cry that we need to
do this in legacy to Ted Kennedy so it
sort of re-energizes the thing gives it
the final push senate passes houses has
got their bill all lined up they've been
working on it like heck for such a long
period of time and then Scott Brown gets
our collective nobody expects Scott
Brown to get elected and what Scott
Brown does is he kills a super majority
in the Senate which means you can't
bring a bill back to the Senate and
repass it so the way this works is
Senate passes a bill House passes a bill
they go into committee and they fight
and they know when they pass their bills
they're not done they put stuff in the
bills that they never expect to become
law because they're going to beach it's
when they get together and negotiate
they don't and they don't worry about
the details because then they know staff
members are going to be up all night
going through every word in fixing the
final bill that will go to the house and
senate and they'll pass together but in
this case
surprise it's brown wins nobody expects
that they lose a supermajority and now
the house is told you have to pass the
Senate's bill or we won't get anything
and the Senate's knows even though they
weren't done with the bill that's what's
bill's going to be in the end so what
you got was a the process was truncated
prematurely and I do think that with
more discussion that they would have
funneled in more stakeholder views that
we this was this may not have been a
long period of time before the final
passage but that's when all the activity
occurs all the horse trading all the all
the practical investment and is this
thing going to work it's when the
lobbyists really rev up and start
talking and saying what the consequences
are we think of lobbies being bad but
they're actually also portraying what
the issues are for the various
stakeholders all of that stuff didn't
happen so then the Affordable Care Act
passes and about 900 to some pages and
it's got ten titles in it but the most
important thing in this bill at least
for my two most important things in the
bill from my perspective were were the
access and enrollment so that's in the
first two titles of this tent first two
sections and you know it attacks the
issue that we've got a lot of uninsured
in the country it's bad for everybody to
have uninsured in this country it's bad
for the uninsured when when untoward
things occur it's bad for the hospitals
in terms of lost revenue it's bad for
planning it's there outside the system
it's bad for everything these people are
are in a very vulnerable position and
we've got by the way Medicaid covering
people in very uneven ways all across
the country this says there should be a
national standard for who's eligible for
Medicaid and the feds say we're going to
step in and help make that possible will
support the states because they support
a lot of budget and they also say
individuals who want to get insurance
are by themselves they can't get
insurance there at the their victims of
the market because they've got no
negotiating power and they said what
we're going to do is create these
exchanges so that people can have
purchasing power when they're going to
buy insurance so that you're not alone
you're with everyone else who needs to
buy insurance and will tear it you can
buy
we're going to say everyone's got to be
in because if everyone's not in then the
insurance as insurance doesn't work it's
going to be too expensive so everyone's
got to be in try to make it affordable
and you'll have the purchasing power of
the group and then so access in
enrollment the other part was quality I
very talk too much but the issue is it's
hard not to be in favor of the fact that
the states that came in have markedly
lowered their unemployment rates the
Medicaid expansion has occurred and in
general it seems like it's been
successful mistakes many other states
pushing back they pushed away federal
dollars and they've had continuing
lehigh uninsured rates they've left
people out and then the exchanges that
you know still have they have further
all their issues they've enrolled
millions and millions of people and
allowed them to take advantage of a
community market advantage that they
wouldn't have had otherwise now the
principal problem with it was
implementation I mean there's lots of
things the bill could have done better
but the implementation side with slots
starting with healthcare.gov but but I
think it's hard to argue that we're not
better off having fewer uninsured larger
incentives for quality in some efforts
to try to reform the way in which care
is delivered so that people can start
focusing on health more than utilization
so anyway that's a long answer but
that's I think where we are and I
couldn't agree more i mean what i often
say to my students is this actually
isn't a particularly remarkable piece of
legislation way and maybe you disagree i
what i say is if we took out the
political hoopla and we closed our eyes
and we just didn't listen to the news
for five or six years this actually
isn't a really big deal like what this
basically did is it kept the system as
it was and it brought more people in and
it basically said to this group of folks
who are self-employed and getting
insurance from the small group market
we're going to fix that section and
we're not really going to touch the
other folks out there with
employer-sponsored insurance we're going
to sort of you know tinker around the
edges on medicare and try to improve the
way we pay but that's not grand reform I
think in many ways that's not the reform
that's it's even necessary to fix us
healthcare system I think what happened
is it got pulled into partisan politics
and and something that to be very very
frank was was basically what was
sketched out by Bush one as his health
reform became you know this sort of
absolute caricature of what it really
was but you know can I just just
gripping him because and you know I
sometimes wonder if Harlan is a
physician or a policy want because he is
such an important presence in Washington
and I think in his role in an outgrowth
of the legislation the pecora board has
really advanced a lot of the focus on
quality but you know I think that what
we have to do and the politics are very
difficult is not not lose sight of the
fact that we have to really enhance and
move this legislation forward because
what it intended to do and what it's
actually been able to do are not a
complete picture yet as an example state
of Connecticut you know was very proud
of the fact that it was one of the first
states to expand Medicaid eligibility
and what they did was they grew in a
period of about 10 years the number of
people insured in Medicaid from 350,000
400,000 to 750,000 and what they did was
they took their funding of that program
for acute care and physician services
down to essentially nothing and they
taxed the hospitals and then they got a
two-third federal match and what happens
is you've got providers not just the
hospitals but physicians who are being
paid forty cents on the dollar of costs
you don't even cover your variable
expenses let alone your fixed expenses
so you have a lot of providers saying
it's not that I don't value this but I
can't afford to provide the care because
it's not being it's not being covered
and when we put open the exchanges again
Connecticut led the way
in building a model for enrollment in
the exchanges what we have found is that
fully a third of the people who went to
enroll in the exchanges were eligible
for Medicaid so it's contributed to the
growth of Medicaid rolls and you have
this incredible imbalance in terms of
what is being used and what's being paid
for and I think that we all recognize
that we need to evolve this to a system
of pain for value rather than just
people with the system but we also have
to recognize while we're making that
transition we have a lot of people
hitting the system and the fact that you
know that this is a federal law and
there hasn't been an even way of
leveling the playing field for access
and service delivery across the states
you know continues to make this an
important work in progress so if I put
you on the spot and I said one change
you gotta we have to introduce one
change the ACA to make it better what's
the what's the change you would push for
one change you know I think the biggest
change that i would put forward is that
we have to level the playing field in
terms of defining what we want who are
ensuring what we want them to have
access to and then what it takes to pay
for that because there's a disconnect
between policy and where we say we want
to go and what we're actually putting in
place to make that happen Harlan with
you if I put you on the spot and I said
the one the one change we need to make
well so there's a lot of changes around
the edges that you could do and there
are a lot of changes that are occurring
that are just occurring to slowly with
regard to the I think the transition to
the way in which we're paying in and our
need for better quality measures and to
be able to to protect people and
increase the transparency you know what
I'd like to see it offends me that we
pay less for certain people in our
society on health care than others and I
think it sends a message that you're not
as your life isn't as worthwhile and
that doesn't mean whether they've access
or not but the notion that
we're paying 40 cents on the dollar for
you and and you're going to get a
premium you know to me sends a message
it's and the way people are received
within healthcare you know when you know
you've got a call from someone you're
going to lose money on I mean let's be
honest people think about margins
they've got to pay your salaries they've
got to stay in business the hospital is
big enough so that probably doesn't
happen but within office settings you
know whether or not you're open to
Medicaid patients how you treat Medicaid
patients what the length of time is for
Medicaid patients Oh everyone knows that
all these things play out in everyday
thing it's a lack of respect and you
know there should be a minimum level
that says you know this is what is needs
to be paid now I understand a tent you
know 10 to 12 of the states have a third
of their budget going for Medicaid so
you've got to figure out where the
revenue side is going to come from but
to make it work by saying to people you
must care for your basically creating
charity care without calling it charity
care and that creates a sense in the
system that leads to unfairness and we
know what parts of the population or
disproportionately bear this kind of
burden and when people when people in
power healthcare professionals are
looking at these people coming in who
are having very inadequate ways of
paying for the care through the
government it just sends I think
messages and I think it affects the
quality of the care as well and the
business model for anyone is to figure
out how do I bring in high margin people
how do I please them how do I make them
have a delightful experience and in
actually if I can be grumpy to the
people who I'm actually losing money on
in even subtle ways it actually makes my
bottom line better and I'm not saying
anyone sitting there thinking at night
how can I do that but in subconscious
ways it would be remiss for us to say
humans wouldn't have that enter into
their minds now you know if you say
we're doing it we're going to double the
excise tax on cigarettes you know things
in our society that are not in people's
best interest that end up raising costs
all the way around in and for which
maybe they've been pulled in by
advertisements and addicted to and we
can find ways to grieve revenue streams
on things like that maybe we can defray
some of the costs but but that was one
of the things i thought that needed to
be addressed it's not just access in
eligibility but
how can we ensure that they are being
respected honored that their care that
they're being that people are being paid
for their care in ways that are
reasonable because I think that it has
reverberations throughout the entire
health care system when you talk about
equity so I know this was going to be
unpopular because when the bill was
scored and when people talk about the
cost I go well how can you possibly pay
more but but is it really a society that
we want to have where somebody's coming
in where everyone knows you're a money
loser you know your money loser when you
come in and if you go somewhere else
better off for me you know that that
can't be the way that place is run and
and that's got so if you ask me you know
it wasn't something anyone touched but
it bothered me it really bothered me and
maybe when we get to more population
based pricing we can see that we're
bundling large groups of people and
we're bundling them all together for
certain amount we're not making a
differentiation and certain populations
are more needy and that'll push us to
give better care to those groups because
we're trying to reduce their healthcare
costs improve their outcomes because of
the one they're ones ultimately who will
break the bank if we're not proactive
and I again hate to put everything in
business terms but that's why medicine
runs and we ever there are dedicated
people health care professionals leaders
like Martin who are inspiring but in the
end of the day she's got a lot of
employees she's got a lot of
responsibilities and she doesn't hit her
bottom line she she's got it she's it's
not going to work the place is going to
close so she's got to figure out how it
works business models have to be aligned
with our values and that's where we've
got to make sure the government's
helping us ensure that what we want as a
society is aligned with the way in which
payment occurs which is pushing us
towards a society we aspire to not the
society we have so that's what I would
like more thought about how the policy
can help create that milieu Harlan and I
as usual thing quite similarly about
these issues you know I one of the
things that I'm most proud of in our
organizations and I'll you
you know yell New Haven Hospital which
at 1500 benzes of behemoth is that I
believe that if you went into any
patient care unit if you went into the
operating rooms if you went into any of
the clinic settings the bed the
treatment Bay the whatever you see a
patient in has nothing to do with their
payer source it is purely based on
patient need and that's been a value
that's saying although that's not true
in the outpatient area but it comes back
to your crime eNOS as a system that's a
value that we set a record to our values
and I think that you know you're right
but you can have really you know
important values like that and you can't
make the business model work and the
conversation that we've been having with
business coalition's is if you look at
our business model in our health system
one out of every four patients cared for
any place on our health system right now
is insured by the state of Connecticut
and we're getting paid about forty cents
on the dollar of cost so we're losing
sixty cents on twenty five percent of
our patients Medicare pays us about 88
cents on the dollar cost and Medicare
throughout the system is about
thirty-seven percent of our patients so
you look at the vast majority of our
patients we do not get paid costs as the
government defines costs for their care
so what happens and has historically
happened is we cost shift to commercial
payers and depending on what those
contracts are who they're with who
you're insuring it can be anywhere from
fifteen percent over cost you know a
hundred and fifty percent of cost the
only populations that are fairly
consistently having their health care
managed now and we do it with our own
employees we have put in place care
coordination models for chronic
asthmatics for people with diabetes
these have been voluntary we haven't
know your numbers program which incense
employees and their dependents
to take costs off of their health
insurance spend if they participate in
healthier behaviors you know GE does it
unites lumen-a ting does it the city of
New Haven is doing it with their insured
patients and that's all good and we
actually have seen some incredible
results we went you know too having a
goal of fifty percent fewer unnecessary
I admit visits to the emergency
department for people with diabetic
crisis in our employee group 20 we
didn't expect to go that fast but it was
not it was just sort of getting involved
getting care managers and working with
our employees and you can change
behaviors the problem is is that we're
changing behaviors and reducing
utilization in a pay for volume system
still on the only patients on whom we
make money so we're kind of doing the
right thing and we're shooting ourselves
in one foot while we're continuing to
see the largest growth in our patient
populations and those insured by the
government where we are being underpaid
where Medicare is once again looking at
the number of people who are hitting
Medicare eligibility and saying we don't
have the money to pay for these people
without bankrupting Medicare and so
while we're investing in the future in
pay for performance and ACO models you
still have a lot of people who are older
who have had unhealthy behaviors who are
hitting the system and who want good
traditional care right now and I think
the problem is is that to solve this you
know we're going to need some working
capital broadly in the system to be able
to build some of the models so that we
can get behaviors and changes in demand
that are ultimately going to start to
align with the goals that you have that
we have that the Affordable Care Act had
but right now there's an imbalance you
know in the overused analogy we got a
foot on the dock and a foot on the boat
in the boat we
want to go someplace but we're stuck in
a care and payment model that is a
necessity because today there were over
twelve hundred and fifty patients in
beds at yale-new Haven Hospital right
now and they really don't care about the
Affordable Care Act they only care that
they're getting safe high quality care
that they're being respected and you
know and they want what they need right
now while we're trying to figure out how
to solve the problem for the future and
it's a very challenging balancing act
right now the other thing just because I
have the microphone and I said I wanted
to challenge our friend Betsy Bradley
who used to be in the School of Public
Health you know Betsy's done a lot of
good work that also says when we look at
how we perform against other developed
countries and you look at the spend on
health care and outcomes you're missing
a big part of the equation which is the
investment in social infrastructure so
that it's more than healthcare you can't
just put it into health care and have
the measure be certain health care
outcomes you know we have to look at you
know education housing things that you
know as a country we have had much more
uneven shall we say to be politically
you know balanced investments in and
when people aren't safe at home when
they can't eat when they're not educated
you're going to get certain behaviors
and lifestyles that are going to
contribute to a potential overuse of the
health care system mm-hmm and one area
that I've talked to Harlan about I think
it's so easy when you have these debates
to have them turn into abstractions but
the privately insured or people on
Medicaid I think what strikes me in
healthcare is if I went around the room
and we were all at a cocktail party and
I told some story about my family and
the medical care of my mom received my
father received somebody would answer
back about a story that they have about
where the US health care system failed
them and hospital-acquired infections
end up being with leading causes of
death in the United States how do we how
do we tackle these quality issues these
these issues that everybody faces in
such an enormous sector of the economy
is this is this an issue Harlem well I
mean I think Martin is the one to answer
this the first locally there's been a
lot of
activity ales got resources and they put
them into trying to make the place safer
there's been a lot of attention to it
I've been a big proponent of
transparency and I think that it's the
exposure of our performance that forces
us to come to terms with what it is
we're achieving in the results that are
being accrued in enforcing us to find
solutions it's when they're they're not
we can't see them we don't understand
them or they're in the back of our minds
but we don't have any sort of
quantitative estimates of what we're
doing and we can't track improvement so
I mean I believe we you know we
published a paper last year that said
in-hospital mortality across all
conditions has dropped about thirty
percent over the last decade
hospitalization rates across all
conditions even at a time when we're
putting together ob's units and other
ways of keeping the hospital even
accounting for that have dropped about
twenty percent and immortality
readmissions after Hospital asians are
also beginning to drop as well so on the
results I don't get any question that
there's marked improvement a lot of our
quality measures are imperfect but they
seem to all be trending the right way
and the hospitals have never been safer
than they are now but but we know one
feels like the the job's done and that
that we don't have a long way to go but
but I think that one of the great
success stories last decade is the way
in which everyone has embraced this
notion that that we may be doing harm
that was unintended and unappreciated
for many years and that now that we can
see it and we're starting to measure it
and report it it becomes a target for
action and that there's been progress
being made but we're still I mean when
you look on the wards we're still
practicing a lot like the 1950s I'm
talking on the dock side you know the
way in which we practice why we're
thinking I mean we don't train people to
be thinking that you know if you don't
wash your hands where we walk in a
patient's room you might as well walk in
with a knife I mean we don't make it
equivalent to the harm the danger you
know of the kind of way that you're
creating a toxic environment safety
issues for patients so we still approach
it very casually so as much as the
hospital puts up on screen savers and as
much as they make hand-washing units and
imperil dispensers available in every
you know every five feet in the
spittle there's still a cultural issue
about saying how can I make this a safe
place why am i waking people up in the
middle of the night why is there so much
noise here what kind of language am i
using that instead of calming people
down is is getting them to be alarmed I
mean why is this patient without two
meals while they're waiting for a
procedure and so they're starving and
they're under malnourished leather here
why have I kept them in bed bed rest and
not allowed them to get strong for the
time when they need to go home because
it's more convenient for us because when
we do rounds we know the better in fact
why on rounds do I not schedule the time
when i'm going to see them during the
day so all day they're in a heightened
sense of anxiety when is a specialist
going to come by to see me the family is
uncertain when that's going to happen
and everyone sort of on edge that if I
go to the bathroom or if I take a walk
around I might miss somebody important
who's coming here to see me so that I'm
uncertain as opposed to giving them a
window I mean we do it at restaurants
why can't we give them little beeper
devices if they want to walk around
starts beep in red that means someone's
in your room waiting to see you we don't
what well I think it well the advance is
seeing through the patient's eyes in
their experience and trying to
understand what does that feel like in
our culture has been about what my day
is light now what their days like and
that's that's the switch on safety
that's a switch on experience that's a
switch on saying it's not just the by
when you leave the hustle but they're
there episode of whatever illness that
is isn't over and they've got to now
deal with whatever else went on so I
think these are the things I'm just done
by the medical profession now that we
have to deal with that we've been far
too permissive about and as we've sat on
a pedestal and then important and you
know major art did everything revolved
around our days that's got to end that's
got it and you know when we become
patients our failures come patients
we're outraged when we're running
through our day we can't see it and so
that's got to start from the training to
the way in which everything is
configured and by the way that we have
to pay attention to the doctor's
experience to they and nurses that they
have to find be able not be tethered to
a monitor they no one wants to be stared
at a monitor instead of the patient but
when you know you've got to spend three
hours at the end of the day doing
paperwork if you don't keep up during
the day
that becomes a problem so all of these
issues about everyone's experience needs
to be paid attention to then we need to
find out what is it going to look like
in 2020 now try to retrofit a culture of
1950 into an era where worlds flat
digital and we have different
expectations and we honestly can do
better than we did ever did before yeah
I you know again you know if you want a
debate pearl and I probably aren't going
to debate because we agree on so many
things but you know I think in the
system what we have achieved and it's an
ongoing journey is to become in the
aerospace and manufacturing industry a
high reliability organization and that
means taking 21,000 of our 21 thousand
employees through training and follow-up
training and reinforcement in behaviors
throughout the organization taking 7,500
members of medical staff some of them
full-time faculty some community-based
through high reliability training in the
concept behind it basically as everybody
has to be two hundred percent
accountable so you know if patient care
associates sees a physician going to
enter a patient's room and hasn't washed
their hands you have a responsibility to
speak up every morning saturday-sunday
every day of the week we have a safety
huddle across the system in every
patient care area they only last about
15 minutes first question is how long
has it been since our last serious
safety event everybody in the
organization who wants to pipe into that
knows that serious safety events are
events of that cause significant harm
you know then we go through our their
safety concerns today what are they they
could be you know as simple
as you know somebody's doing some
flushing in the water system and we want
to be sure that people in a certain
building are aware that there could be a
backup in such and such an area or they
could be you know very significant
issues we go through best catch awards
safety catch awards you know did
anything happen in the last 24 hours
that was really remarkable there are
almost every day there are amazing
safety catches you know some of the
worst events that I've seen in our
organization recently have been one offs
we look at them and you say nothing that
we had in place could have prevented
this as it was so what you got to do you
know is be able to deal with those
openly and honestly do root cause
analyses and this is iterative we are
never going to be there it is a constant
journey toward making care more
predictable more patient focused more
evidence-based and it is everybody's
responsibility and human behaviors such
that when you got many different people
with varying at levels of education on
different shifts in it getting people to
all focus on the same thing in the same
way you know is an extraordinary
challenge in human behavior but it has
been demonstrated to have great impact
on safety and quality in other fields
and you know that's where we're going to
have to do it's not magic its blocking
and tackling and its operating with
values I mean I so I wasn't a communist
I think about this as incentives and I
think the the idea of the airline
industry is a fascinating one and why
they've been so quick to adopt safety
changes and I think fundamentally it is
an accountability issue it's that if I
as the pilot don't follow safety regs I
go down with the ship right if we
started cutting off doctors hands if
they didn't wash you know their patients
got infections that the hand-washing
rate I've got a country for you to go
right but it's but it's fundamentally an
accountability and I think one of the
challenges is how do we increase it and
with these bigger healthcare
organizations where it's but not in a
punitive way
you know you have to start fingers not
breakfast but you have to start trying
to make it safe and for people to do
that and to move forward you know and
move to progressive levels of discipline
and accountability but you know when we
started reporting this we saw serious
safety events rise extraordinarily and
you know everybody said oh my gosh are
we getting worse and what you really
realize was that people just weren't
sharing the information before and so
then you get to a new baseline you
understand what's contributing to that
and then start moving but you have to
you know the airline industry has has
proven that you have to be able to make
it reasonable safe and you know
blameless for people to start helping
you get at systemic you know problems
with yes we should open it up so we have
some some roving mics oh yeah these are
all for you Marta yeah I hope David Lee
shoots class of 80 and a shout out to my
classmate Harlan for a wonderful
presentation um so bumper sticker think
globally act locally the health care
system a lot of you were talking about
global changes about incentivizing
doctors generally think in terms of
medicine by patient not in terms of
population in terms of public health are
the incentives mis-matched for the
medical students that you train for the
system that you manage at yale-new haven
and how do we align those incentives so
that the doctor the nurse the health
care professionals incentives are
aligned with the system well i'll just
quickly say on the on our side on them
on the physician side they're terribly
misaligned and the doctors in the
university at this point are paid
largely by relative value units which
creates intense competition among the
doctors to grab relative value units
which is collision audience it's sort of
the time the doctor spent had sore been
quantified in terms of what the
contribution
is in its it's skewed towards procedures
so you can do one procedure and that
would be like seeing 20 patients in the
outpatient so it pushes you to want to
do procedures it pushes you to want to
see people rapidly it pushes you away
from things like teaching and teamwork
and it pushes you towards making sure
you grab your relative values because at
the end of the year people come to you
and say you're at a thousand and you're
at 1,500 and people get ranked and their
compensation is all based on that
instead of creating a milieu where we
come together and create joint goals for
the team and the degree to which the
team achieves those goals is degree to
which we all share in what that benefit
should be and that if there are people
who aren't contributing well to that the
team itself has got to work that through
just like you would on any successful
team about whether people are playing
their position right and whether they're
helping people around them be better but
there's no consideration of that it's
all my individual RV use if I'm a
clinician and it's driving people
towards perverse behaviors that lead
them not to necessarily think about the
patient but to think about their
accumulation of our views not outcomes
not quality and I would push the most
important thing in medicine today that
we could teach is teamwork it's not
about us but it's how well the team is I
may be amazing but if I don't have
everyone around me be amazing or if I'm
not a good teammate ensuring that
everyone is communicating collaborating
coordinating for the benefit of the
patient then we failed I don't care how
good a surgeon I am if rehab doesn't
work or if the whole team doesn't work
we lose and if we lose we shouldn't be
rewarded we've got to get that mentality
into medicine doesn't exist right now
and we're not paid like that so for that
reason you've got I think fixed that
that's one piece to fix there's other
issues around the hospital compensation
and other things that can be fixed but
that's a very important one that's a
problem I would add to Harlan's bumper
sticker it's teamwork and communication
because that's been an issue but what
we've done in that and the health system
is every employee including you know the
people who are burnishing the floors in
the evening have an incentive plan and
what they are incented to do and to
perform to is the same stuff that I am
incented to there are you know we're
built off of the same incentive plan
and they are very specific measures of
patient safety and quality patient
satisfaction patient engagement employee
engagement because if the employees
aren't you know plan then you're not
going to get any of this done and forth
is financial performance but we're all
we all have the same line of sight and
it's not perfect but you know it helps
to create some alignment that didn't
exist before it's much better in annual
reviews and specific and explicit goals
and of which part of them are how people
work together the hospital and health
system has been much better than
university that way yes we're going to
push from there back in the in the left
oh you can die wherever you hey adrian
thomas class of 98 and full disclosure
an orthopedic surgeon in private
practice in New Hampshire so I'm a
little bit different than the academic
world you guys room but I came from an
academic place with regards to you know
I think of Public Health a pic of
preventive medicine you know I think of
keeping people healthy not treating the
sick almost ironically the question
being is now everyone has insurance but
in a lot of states people are still
seeing an increased number of ER visits
because there aren't enough primary care
doctors out there so my question is what
is the AC air and general health care
reform doing to create more primary care
doctor so that people aren't using the
ER still as their primary care doctor
because then they're only going for
events not going for preventative care
and I feel like if we increase my
preventative care we have we can
decrease overall costs I think the
solution that is pay orthopedic surgeons
less than pay primary care more in car
and cardiologists and cardiologists less
in primary care more
I mean so the answer the federal level
is at least coming out of the their
executive group is is I think they know
that they haven't been focusing on it
you know in a sense they've been
focusing on the wiring for the last five
years and I think what they're trying to
do is change the conversation now the
ACA is out there I think you're starting
to see it in benefits designs and I
think at least in terms of ER use that's
going to be the the most effective
strategy it's something that thank you
only Haven is thinking about internally
I have to pay more if I go in direct via
an ER than i do if i go to an urgent
care clinic right we ought to put a
financial incentive to that so that the
person has to make a choice to have a
different view on that I think that
first of all you know the ACA did have a
one of those sections I talked about the
ten sections was on workforce but
actually they never even populated the
workforce there was because of the
descent and they never actually
constituted that group ecori would was
one group the workforce a group was
another they never constituted but I
think one better use of non physicians
nurse practitioners are key and need to
be part of this and probably it needs to
be teamwork issue and then the second
thing is I don't think anything wrong
with the ED for as an urgent care place
especially if it's not busy that we
can't charge ed rates if people are
coming in and using it for that but we
have sometimes we have unused capacity
in Edie's for people who need things
people already go into minute clinics
and other places I think about medicine
it's going to be where do you need the
relationships and where is their
commodity and medicine that you just
need I just in my throat swab and
actually I mean I don't need a more and
that's just my view that there's some
commodity services that could be created
in very efficient ways there are other
areas that were nurse practitioners and
doctors need to have a relationship with
you and are helping you through other
things and we need to be creative about
how we're going to make that I don't
think the answers when you're going to
double the primary care Doc's but I
think I think it's in sentence
incentives you know I think the best
analogy for me say you know eating right
like i imagine i didn't have to pay for
the food i got and i wanted to get a
quick lunch there's nothing stopping me
from going to the union league cafe
popping in clicking out you know picking
up a quick bite you live in pearson how
much do you dare fair enough but what we
want is
we give meals free we need people to to
have a stake and where they go people
make amazingly good choices right when
they have the ability to choose and
there are sensible incentives in the
system and I think until you know if we
always have it be the same price for
going to an ER as going to a minute
clinic as going to an outpatient clinic
is going to an urgent care clinic you go
into primary care people are going to
use the most intense most convenient
option and I think fundamentally that's
a it's a price story and I think that's
a benefit design yeah please so if you
started with the conversation basically
staying a great d HD a how it is
absolutely everybody and I got to tell
you that I listened to you and your
entire most of your comments who are
about and respecting the people of the
facilities if you will if you think
about the health care system was
providers labs and facilities and if you
think about people you've got people in
groups have people individuals your
people who are uninsured I'll grant you
that uninsured more of them could have
coverage nowadays I won't speak by fruit
in terms of the individual market which
you started off the conversation about
how the individual market has improved
because basically people now have more
buying power if you will I think that's
100
diametrically opposed what's really
happened in the individual larger place
people are there are fewer choice of
animals before the new york state
officers and drop has essentially
converted their individual plans over to
basically an exchange rates planet and
those dropped out and the exchange based
plans have very limited network suit we
think about most of the healthcare
people walking up you go to a provider
he goes a facility I grant you
everything you said about the facilities
what has to be approved there but help
its chamber I can go to a provider and
with the result of the application for
those of us who have forced into the
digital marketplace he's got very very
little choice a very very narrow
networks so my question to you I do have
a question after all basically you know
if you can put aside the statement says
this was the best thing since sliced
bread and all that do you see any hope
to address what a really fundamental the
ACA Act made things worse for those of
us before individual individual market
placement and a few years ago do you
have any thoughts as to but have
individual marketplace can be improved
or basically as far as you're concerned
it's a it is improved it is better what
and by the way your point United just
threatened to drop out of some of the
exchanges yeah you're United yeah you
you know you know of one the one one
thing I would say I think you're
absolutely correct but each state is
different so in Connecticut the
exchanges have really not narrowed
networks at all but they are very
expensive they are essentially
catastrophic insurance so people who go
in as you know individuals into that
market have very broad choice in general
anthem you know has largely most of the
payers have largely priced their
premiums off of other commercially
available products but the problem is is
that for you know most people as i said
the out of pocket up front before they
run through a deductible and copay is
just horrific alee expensive and you
know i think it comes back to I you know
and they're so you guys are much smarter
about this and I
but a big philosophy about how much
states rights prevail because the states
have a very big role in the health
insurance business and they're all over
the place and the politics are very
local and they're very parochial and I
think that they have not produced what
was intended in large measure in that
portion of the legislation Commissioner
with jack has said I just want to say I
wasn't suggesting that the thing was
Nirvana just that it I thought it had
advanced by putting more people into
insurance what do you think about what's
going to prove the market so I think so
two things so I think there is a
fundamental tension between Ford ability
and network sighs and I think that's
something that's going to play out over
the next 10 or 15 years and basically if
you want an affordable plan I think the
trade-off is you're gonna have to a
state you're going to have to sort of
deal with a narrow network and I think
that's that's here to stay i think what
we'll fix the insurance markets and it's
it's something we've got to think about
as these markets change is competition
in these insurance markets and how much
competition there is in many ways that's
why i find some of the market changes
that we're seeing the mergers of
proposed mergers of Etna and Humana
anthem and Cigna coming together because
we really want are these large firms
competing against each other for our
business and when companies like United
pull out and when the number of choices
in these exchanges goes down it leads to
precisely the results that you're
talking about hi Ron gold sir 75 I'm
from Minnesota where mayo clinic is
located first I echo Mordecai's concerns
about the individual market my premiums
are going up 50 50 percent this coming
year that's pretty big but I'd like to
go back to the first question which had
to do with your compensation method
method the RV use and quality care team
work I wonder whether there's a piece of
the chain that you have not addressed
yet and that is the relationship between
the insurer and the provider in terms of
the method of payment seems to me that
even with the compensation method that
you described which I believe Mayo
Clinic also uses the billing that comes
out of the provider to the insurer is
still fee for service
and if if you're only getting paid forty
cents on the dollar for Medicaid fee for
service and 88 cents or 82 cents on the
dollar for Medicare fee-for-service
aren't we ultimately better off with a
service that has outcome best based in
terms of how reimbursement is is done
and if that's true what is the
alternative and for whatever alternative
you choose how do you get from here to
there yeah I mean that's how do we so I
think everyone knows payment needs to
change from fifa service to some level
of capitation and i think you described
if one foot on the boat one on the dock
it's going to happen and i think the
honest answer is nobody really knows
quite how to get there the argument that
the administration is making is that
Medicare is the biggest payer and so if
we can get them paying for quality
that'll create the air space for the
insurers to follow behind I think what
you'll see in these areas were and this
is actually the counter argument that
the insurers will make for becoming
bigger is that the bigger they are the
more they'll have the heft to change the
way they pay I think what you want to
move away from is so this rvu system is
its counter to the best interest of the
entire system yes in the the issue I
mean you see things like I mean I have
friend who is a Duke who told me that at
the upper levels of the leadership there
they would spend some part of the
meeting figuring out whether or not the
MRIs were running 24 hours a day you
know what what was keeping them from
running 24 hours a day why wasn't the
volume of when I would start off and I
remember going into clinic and seeing a
sign on the wall saying we have two
spots open in the echo of schedule today
can anyone fill them you know it I'm in
an academic practice I'm on salary but
still there's a sense of needing to
utilize the machinery and capacity that
we have in order to maximize its
potential I'll put it like that in a
polite way you know and so that the
issue I think we'd be better off going
to an outcomes-based way and there's
lots the hips and knees now out of
Medicare are going to be bundled to
large extent so it's going to put an
emphasis on the episode of care is the
patient experiences it and the outcomes
of the patients receive we were part of
our group developed the quality measures
that are going to go along with that
which include pain and function and how
people feel so that we can assess how
successful the surgery was now the issue
is going to make sure the case makes
adjustments right so that people don't
refuse to do surgery in certain people
because they think it's going to make
them they're harder surgeries and they
make them look worse so it's about
getting that right but I can see a
movement in this direction which is
going to incentivize us to work together
and it's going to incentivize us to
produce results that are going to be
transparent and for which we're going to
be accountable and for which payment is
going to be aligned it's already
happening the Secretary of HHS has made
a commitment that that a high percentage
of the care is going to be paid for in
value she's making a promise that we
can't deliver on because we don't have
the metrics to do it but you can see us
moving in that direction and I'll make
one example of an I want to give you the
final word a readmissions are the
perfect example Harlan's the national
leader and studying them what is it one
in five Medicare patients get readmitted
there's a grip there's a hospital in New
York that has basically done a
phenomenal job getting down readmissions
and and even with the quality payments
in their ACA it's not profitable right
because in a sense the readmissions that
they are now avoiding also represent a
loss in revenue on until fundamentally
you lose money doing the wrong thing
this won't work and I guess the question
is how are how are you preparing to make
this transition as when you see it
happening I boy I you know I honestly
can't answer that so what we're doing
organizationally is saying we have one
overarching strategy for everybody and
that is to provide unparalleled value to
the patients and families we serve value
is defined as the quality safety patient
experience / the cost price point
because fundamentally how quickly we
change how much we change who changes
value is still going to be important
under a better fee-for-service system or
under a paint of paper value system and
so you know we've got I would say you
know
number ninety percent of our you know
employees physicians everybody focused
on how do you maximize value under the
current system because you know they're
coming to work every day how do you make
care better safer and more cost
effective and then we've got you know
sort of a skunk works and it much less
than ten percent of the organization
focused on how do you deconstruct a
population health model and then rebuild
it both understanding the insurance and
financial risk components but more
important having in place the connective
tissue that allows you to not rely on
just you know in Harlan said it earlier
physicians offices the acute care
setting and traditional post acute care
but you know really bring in everything
from home care to digital medicine to
everything else because and you know and
then when you actually make the
transition so that you've got ninety
percent of the organization dealing with
that and ten percent you know dealing
with legacy systems I couldn't begin to
predict that well there we go we could
keep having this conversation for hours
and we are out of time well I hope this
is a conversation you continue out there
we're all happy to continue with you
we're delighted to see you here welcome
back to campus and and thanks for coming
to our panel
you